welcome back to another episode of the
recruitment mentors podcast i'm your
host heisha mazouz
and i'm really excited to be joined by
george today and this is a another
installment of our short series that
we're doing called early on in
recruitment where basically i'm sitting
down with recruiters that are early on
in their career we're talking the first
12 18 months and we're finding out
what have been some of their biggest
challenges what have they learned along
the way so far advice that they can
share with us that could be helpful for
people that are still early on in their
career and also to talk about why we
believe more people should be choosing a
career in recruitment
so george thank you for joining me
thanks for having me here
and look where we're going to start of
all of these uh is just to find out
how has recruitment compared to what you
expected george talk to him about that
um so to be honest i didn't really know
what to expect i feel like like most
recruiters i sort of just fell into the
career didn't really know what to do
with my life or what to expect after
finishing off at uni um i knew that
involves helping other people get jobs
and it sounded like a pretty simplistic
career but obviously in terms of that i
couldn't be more wrong
so
you expected it to be
simple speak to people that want jobs
how how is it actually been how would
you describe it now
um so i mean it's probably slightly more
high stress than i thought it would be
there's a lot there's a lot going on
lots of things to learn and lots of
things to remember um the training that
i had was pretty quick and it was
obviously really really efficient so i
was able to get onto the job quicker
probably than i thought it would be
um but yeah i mean overall i'm enjoying
it a lot more than i thought i would um
i'm working a lot harder than i thought
i've ever have previously um so yeah i
mean overall it's definitely a really
positive thing for me um sort of wish i
did it straight after uni uh rather than
uh doing anything in between
so okay so with that then
if you're if we're in a pub right now
and you're surrounded by people that
might have just graduated people that
are looking for their first job
how would you describe recruiting to
them
um
lots of lots of negotiation uh lots of
trying to understand people
or maybe a slightly deeper level than if
you would just be having a casual
conversation with someone
it's about understanding people's
driving factors and underlying
motivations
handling objections is a big part of it
of course like and you learn pretty
early on that the first time someone
says they're not interested in working
with you and they give you a reason it's
not necessarily the real reason so i
guess it's about sort of digging up
people's true reasons and real natures
of what they're looking for
okay
so i always like asking this question
what what skills or experience and has
recruitment given you so far that maybe
you you least expected it sounds like i
didn't have any major expectations but
yeah what what is it maybe giving you
that you've been surprised by
um yeah i guess like i say understanding
people um
some people call it social engineering
uh something i'm very interested in so
i've sort of just finished a book uh by
a top fbi negotiator uh discussing about
uh of course negotiating christopher
that's absolutely yeah exactly yeah
that's the one reader yeah never split
the difference you have to read the book
i would direct it honestly i would
recommend that to anyone starting out in
recruitment or even later in your
journey in recruitment
exactly yeah i mean and that's another
thing um recruitment i feel like has
allowed me to develop into a version of
myself that i wouldn't necessarily have
been able to
activate if it wasn't for this job i
mean uh
these are these are skills you do on the
job right but they're applicable to
pretty much any any sort of social
interaction you might have whether it's
like you said in the pub or whether it's
uh something a bit more serious um and
yeah just just anything everything's so
applicable um and it's definitely helped
me a lot in areas outside of work as
well
so let's just talk about that for a
second because this this honestly came
out in the last series and i don't want
to put words in your mouth but i'll ask
you a question
your friends family would they do you
think they would describe you as someone
after like with your nine or so months
in recruitment do you think
they would describe george as someone
that's more confident
yeah i think definitely um i've never
really had too much of an issue with
confidence or meeting new people um
which i think has actually helped me a
lot with the job but um definitely i've
seen improvements within myself and i
like to think that
family and friends would have noticed
improvements as well in terms of this
sort of stuff
um yeah now i'm definitely definitely
more confident more able to sort of
speak to anyone uh without any sort of
formal
interaction but yeah i mean so physical
cold calls seem a lot easier i guess
there's one way
yeah sure no no thanks for sharing that
i just just find that interesting a lot
of people share the it's actually
yeah there was someone that was maybe a
bit confident or didn't have as much
confidence going in but since they've
been on this journey it's given them the
confidence to communicate comfort is a
good relationship speak to people and
yeah that's such a positive
uh that can have such a positive impact
on your life as a whole not just in a
work context so i was curious to ask
that
so
i'm sure you would have heard it but
a very common sentence that people
typically hear is like
the first year in recruitment can be the
toughest
so
let's dive into like
the the hard parts of this journey so
far right because you're you're like
nine months in right so you are in the
thick of this this journey getting to
that first year mark which is really
exciting
so talk to me about i guess
what has been the sort of lowest low so
far like recruitment's a roller coaster
that's what this podcast used to be
called because i experienced that
firsthand so like talk to us about your
lowest days so far and we can then talk
about what you learned from it or how
you got through it
yeah so i mean i i had maybe a slightly
different um
initial path into recruitment in my
first year so i was sort of lucky enough
to have quite a quick rise to success
this is uh mainly down to the mentors
i've had along the way my team leader um
the the training i received as i
mentioned before um but yeah i found
success quite quickly um and my first
few months were easier probably than
some other people around me who also
worked incredibly hard um so i was i was
going to a point where i was averaging
about three deals a month
um pretty early on and then suddenly
everything went wrong so i had a drop
out and then
one manager of a role i'd been working
really hard at uh decided they were
going to have a hiring freeze with no
notice uh and another one i was doing
the same sort of work rate on uh they
filled the role internally with again no
notice um and then so
i think it was a bit harder as well
because i got really psyched up to have
my best my best month yet um and
obviously it then turned out to be my
worst um and although in comparison with
a lot of people it wouldn't be such an
awful month i just feel like because i
was everything was going so well and i
was really feeling the sort of
skyrocket to success and then it just
got completely blocked um it what it was
quite tough uh what i did was um i took
a few days off to reflect and process
everything and that doesn't mean go down
the pub with the boys it's more just
sort of sit and take take some time
listen to my christmas audio book
and yeah and like just sort of walk the
dog and just think about what i could
have done better
why
it's important to sort of taper the
expectations a bit if that makes sense
um and i do this thing where when i
struggle with things i sort of like to
think about
all the other difficulties i've overcome
previously so i think okay this is hard
but what else have i done that's hard
and got through
x y and z and then i sort of think okay
in comparison this isn't that bad this
isn't that bad and if i've overcome that
stuff previously then why am i worried
about this and then also it sort of
reminds me how strong i am able to be
even if i sort of forget that in a
difficult time that's again something i
encourage other people to do as well
i love that so talk to us about
feel free to get specific here because i
think would be helpful for people but
maybe when that happened and you made
that space to reflect which i absolutely
love by the way what were like the
one to three key things that you sort of
walked away with from that space that
you gave yourself on like right i felt
like i could have done this better or
next time i'm gonna make sure i do this
like what were like the one or three key
takeaways that you took from that that
space of reflecting on on that period
um it was
reminding myself that it is a roller
coaster rather than just a skyrocket
type of career pathway um so it sort of
reminded me that i need to stay a bit
grounded obviously not be cocky about i
mean i wouldn't say i'm a cocky person
but i reminded myself that okay george
it's not always going to go this way
humbled you yeah exactly 100 at humble
mess that's the best way to put it um
yeah it made me more
sort of inquisitive into
managers processes so i can sort of try
and
notice these signs of when things might
go on earlier um and then sort of notice
when when things are going to go wrong
and then act accordingly about it yeah i
think at the beginning i definitely was
i think
i'm sure you may have
sort of uh reflected on this or found
yourself doing this but when when you're
early on you can
you you're just looking for the yeses
and you're looking for the reasons why
things are going to work
right so yeah i'm not i'm not surprised
that that came out that so you've
learned that so maybe there might have
been moments
when that client uh was speaking to you
that you could have gone ah
that's interesting you know you said
that you met that person like how far
has that gone internally right and
there's but you maybe didn't want to ask
that question because that would have
meant that your process would stop and
that would potentially uh ruin your your
best every month right yeah exactly
everything's rose-colored glasses when
nothing's gone wrong at that point so it
was important and i'm glad it happened
in hindsight um because it reminded me
that i need to
really be more sort of aware of these
sort of things that can go wrong and
look for the nose rather than look for
the yeses exactly yeah but best piece of
advice one of the best pieces of advice
i got early on was like ask a question
that you don't hear the answer to that's
because at the beginning you don't want
to do that
so okay cool thank you for sharing that
so
talk to us about let's sort of uh
turn this into a positive then
even though we just did but like talk to
me about what's been sort of your most
memorable day so far
um i mean that that's a bit of a hard
one i mean i've had a lot of memorable
times
i've i work with so many truly inspiring
people like i'm sort of surrounded by
people who
motivate me to be the best version of
myself and if i ever feel a bit tired or
feel like oh what's the point i sort of
look around and i'm like these people
are just not quitting and this is what i
need to be like um i mean recently we
had our work summer party um and this
was just after i had my best weekend
recruitment ever so i managed to it was
some of it was quite lucky i can't put
it all down to hard work but um
i managed to close three deals in a week
and the total value the estimated total
deal value was around 150k euros um so
when i got to the summer party i was
sort of just getting so much love and
support from everyone and i've kind of
never
feared i'm not trying to get too
emotional here right but i i've never
feel so value valued in anything i've
done
um and i mean there was there were new
people who had just started pulling me
aside saying oh mate what's the trick to
success how have you managed to do it i
wanted i want to have the same root as
you and it just sort of felt incredible
like i've never been that guy in
anything before this job so it sort of
reinforced the fact that recruitment has
truly allowed me to become the best
version of myself and also a version
that i actually didn't really believe
was possible in myself to be completely
honest yeah that's that's amazing george
thanks for sharing that so much like are
you in contract yeah i do contract
so look i'd be stupid not to ask you
george but when people ask you that
internally what's the response that's
what people want to know how can
people listen and when they want to get
their runners up quickly they want to
have this success quickly what what was
you responding to people when they were
going george i want to sort of get to
the position you are in or what has been
the secret what what did you share with
them
so for every everyone has their own sort
of flair or their own sort of thing that
makes them a bit more niche or a bit
more unique right but for me i think
there's one thing that everyone has
that's undeniable and i'm sure you know
what i'm about to say you gotta work
seriously hard um and sort of just
really embrace the grind without
sounding too cringy i mean you gotta
just take it as it comes and just really
really go for it um and then also i
think
be innovative so one thing that i try
and do is always do things that
no one else is doing or very limited
people are doing like i mean
there's obviously work smart and work
hard but i think it's the combination of
the two so work incredibly hard and
never stop trying and never give up and
always be resilient but also
calling through
and i mean there's a time in a place for
it right i'm not saying never do it but
calling through lists and lists and this
that you have on a crm
won't necessarily
net you the same amount of success
as
spending
maybe a quarter or a third of your time
thinking about things and just observing
and seeing what people aren't doing
and then going after routes to success
that no one else is doing or any minimal
people are doing
i love that monster
i'd be stupid again not to follow up
yeah give me an example one of those
things that maybe you think you did
differently or wasn't on the red or
other people that ended up sort of
playing out for you i'm curious
um so i guess uh i use different
introductions to get in touch with
managers
than other people i think the idea of
sending spec cvs on email and just
keeping your fingers crossed is uh i
mean it works for some people and it
works if you do a lot but i think i
tried to make it more tailored so you've
got to go after managers who are hiring
for a specific skill set that you know a
bit about and you've got some market
insights relating to that or maybe even
trying to
pull some roles for
engineering managers and heads of uh
technology in companies so that you can
sort of speak to them about a role that
interests them uh and obviously do it in
a sort of
reality exactly yeah a reverse head time
i mean i try and do it in a real way
with a real role but uh just doing
anything that will give you a leg up and
sort of make managers think oh i
remember that guy like in a way that
other people don't maybe video intros as
well i like to try and do video intros
to managers rather than just send them a
message and an ad on linkedin
nice yeah look i think what i take there
is like yeah just be open-minded yeah
and try different things don't
be complacent and don't be la everyone
else is doing it this way so i'm only
going to do it this way like yeah that's
brilliant so and almost even the
opposite of that if you see everyone's
doing it one way then you're not gonna i
mean you're gonna have to be working two
or three times as hard as anyone else to
be able to stand out in that way so it's
almost if everyone's doing it one way
that should almost be not a turn-off to
doing it that way but i mean it's just
it's an eye-opener right so yeah so what
what did you learn then in your first
six months that you wish you'd known
from day one
um
probably
a few different things i guess
again the idea of social engineering and
negotiation understanding people is
really important maybe the value of hard
work
and then also
knowing that it's not always going to be
easy i wish i sort of knew earlier on
that there will be harder times and then
i wouldn't have taken it for granted as
much that i was lucky enough to have a
quick success rate originally
so let's talk about this because you
mentioned this a few times like
about the the challenge and everything
like i know you really wanted to talk a
bit about resilience right and it is a
word that obviously in the recruitment
industry gets shut around really easily
so i guess
firstly a few things here that i want to
get your thoughts on firstly like what
what does resilience mean to you i'm
sure you've you may even said people to
now like you have to be resilient or
like yeah resilience is important but
like what does resilience mean to you
george yeah i mean so it's it's a staple
of the job i think i've i started with
um i think it was six or seven other
people uh in my group um all of them
have now left other than me in that
group um and i think a key part of that
or a key reason is because things go
wrong for people and they don't or they
haven't necessarily developed that
mindset of bouncing back from it so i
guess for me it's about having a certain
mindset that means when things go wrong
you can sort of say okay cool that's
gone wrong it's not ideal but i'm gonna
keep working and every every time
someone says no it takes you closer to
it yes
and like so you said obviously a number
of people will start at the same time
aren't there what like how have you got
better how have you sort of developed or
worked on that bounce back muscle how
have you you said that obviously earlier
you took some time out to reflect but
what do you feel do you do maybe on a
daily weekly consistent basis that helps
you build that muscle because yeah
something that
yeah you have to build over time right
and continue to work on
yeah exactly it's like about building a
mindset and
training yeah like you said training
that muscle of resilience and i guess
it's changing my outset somewhat someone
said to me in a training session that
there's two ways to think about this job
you can either think of it as an
obligation that like i've got to get up
at whatever time 6 30 7 in the morning
go work an 8 or 9 hour day come back put
in a couple of extra hours because i
really want it
and then go to bed and do it all again
and people think of it as an obligation
whereas you've got to flip the mindset
and think of it as an opportunity where
it's like i've now got the opportunity
to
uh have financial freedom
probably much more quickly than most
other careers that are out there that
don't require years and years of
training like being a doctor or a lawyer
or anything like that um and then also
it's thinking about
the reasons why you do things i mean
it's like you can think of stuff as i
should do that i should make an extra
call i should work an extra hour i
should really try a bit harder at
sourcing this role and a lot of people
have the mindset of i should do that and
then that's where it stops but it's
about switching that to thinking i need
to do that and it's like if i'm going to
be successful there's no point thinking
i should do that it's that i need to do
that so i'm going to make it happen
seems like you've really i love that
you've really bought into like cult
event in your mindset
yeah it's like it's one of the things i
pride myself on and i've really sort of
since starting this job become kind of
obsessed with that whole sort of uh
upgrade in the mindset thing
personal development improvement i love
that but what i also take from that and
this is going to be a theme i just know
it is you take an accountability
responsibility for that
it's not yeah it's not like you're
relying on other things or yeah like
you've taken responsibility for that
yeah definitely i mean if if things are
going wrong i mean if things are going
right you don't want to say oh things
are going right for me because of
someone else you want to say things are
going right for me because i've worked
hard so it's the same way of if things
are going wrong you've got to think
about things have gone wrong because i
didn't do enough i didn't probe around
the objections enough or i didn't look
out for these negative signs it's like
things go right it's because of you but
then in the same way the only way to
really enjoy that and really feel that
way is when things go wrong
is you as well and embracing that
mindset
yeah so some people aren't wanting to do
that so that's what i wanted to point
out so just look i'm just curious like
if if you're i don't know how you how
you feel about this or what you have to
share but i just wanted to ask you like
with you going on this journey then of
this of this like my of you being on
this mindset really buying into that
how is that like how have you found have
you found like you being different to
your friends
that's a bit of a weird question but
like i guess what i'm trying to say is
this i think i'd look from the
conversations i have as you as you grow
older like your friends change and these
things and i think sometimes it'll be
really challenging for people where
people might be listening to this and
they've really bought into recruitment
they've really invested themselves and
then they their friendship group are
still people that are like and there's
no judgement here but people that aren't
on that wavelength have you found that
and have you had to deal with that i
don't know i just thought i'd ask that i
was just curious it might be useful for
people i don't know
yeah i mean
people on
i mean a lot of my friends are in quite
high stressful jobs where there is
opportunity to be successful um but i
mean it's you're always going to get
that sort of pushback from people who
say like
why are you still working let's go pub
or like just something like that or just
general sort of things that
aren't going to contribute to success i
mean that's obviously the easy path so
that's the thing that the majority of
people are doing so i mean as much as
it's important to if you're working hard
to enjoy yourself at the same time and
uh
if you're if you're experiencing sort of
financial freedom then do things with it
that make you happy and reward yourself
for hard work but at the same time
you've got to put that hard work in so
in general i think i have had
times when sometimes my friends or
people aren't as
happy with me as they could be because
i'm sort of thinking
i need to they're like oh you could just
work from home today i'm like no because
i'm more productive in the office so i'm
not gonna work from home and get to the
pub for half five i'm gonna go to the
office and if i get there at seven i get
there at seven or if i don't come
because i've got other stuff to do then
i don't come because
my
success sort of has to come before
everything else
um and like you said it's a maturity
thing and it's not that any of my
friends are immature obviously um it's
going public i wouldn't want a bad mouth
anywhere but i don't know i was always
because of that i was just being honest
i appreciate that it was just i think it
could be an interesting part of life
right where like you're clearly like
really committed to
maximizing this opportunity that you've
got and sometimes you can like this is
all part of it right read any post
development but they're going to tell
you the average of however many people
you're with right so i just thought i'd
ask you because i think sometimes this
can be an interesting challenge for
people as they go through life where
they find themselves that actually the
friends that they originally had don't
end up having the same aspirations and
that can be sometimes difficult
definitely definitely and i mean it's
it's a case of i think some people have
this
some people are happy with going to a
job checking in working eight hours
checking out and then you're just
chilling for the evening and you're
relaxing on the weekend and that's fine
like if you find it not a problem at all
but some people i think have sort of
more of an inbuilt drive whether it's
from
what it could be from anything but uh
some people have an inbuilt drive to be
the best that they can possibly be and
the best version of themselves and i
definitely if i'm not
being the best version of myself i don't
feel satisfied and it does sort of
bother me a bit so it's like yeah if you
do have that mindset then it's a great
career to get into
so how look you you've really you've
really sort of been honest here around
like your commitment work ethic
so i had this question from a number of
people like i i wanted to ask you so how
how have you sort of handled your
work-life balance how have you gone
about handling that do you feel like
you've got a good grasp of that do you
feel like you've you're happy leaning
more into work like how how have you
handled that so far
yeah i mean i at this stage i'm
definitely happier leaning more into
work i have a lot more of a purpose and
um
yeah i mean it it's different because i
sort of went from uni to a job where it
was fully remote work as much or as
little as you want sort of basic data
entry type stuff
um and it was a sort of thing you could
do while you're watching netflix in the
background so it was just sort of a case
of if i want to
work four hours of the day i can if i
want to work an hour if i don't want to
do anything i don't have to so like
getting into something that has a more
strict regime um
not in a negative way like it's got a
more strict regime of you've got these
hours to work
each week yeah you can work from home
these days back these days it is
something that was a big challenge early
on because of course at uni it's a case
of like you want to miss your 9 a.m
lecture no worries you can probably
watch it back online like you want to
like watch it the next week because you
you're going out that way cool um but
yeah i mean it's
it's been a big change but i think i
have adapted to it i mean i'm lucky
enough that i've got a great working
environment a lot of
the people i work with uh do go out and
socialize a lot we've got a lot of work
events and uh sort of nights out we do
um but yeah i mean i'm a strong believer
of when it is time to
put in a serious shift then you might as
well do it properly it's the old cliche
if a job's worth doing it's worth doing
well so when it is work time
it is work time like i'm not going to be
distracted by anything
love it so look you've mentioned
training a couple of times
yeah i wanted to make sure i asked this
because you've shared that what what do
you think the sort of best training
advice or piece of advice from training
that you've received
sort of so far that you feel like has
really
worked for you since sort of going on
this journey
um so i mean
it's there's a lot of things there's a
lot of things but i mean i i would say
know your market um unders whatever
market you're in make sure you
understand the ins and outs and people
will tell you things and it's very easy
to sort of
know a few definitions of the market and
like but it's important to sort of delve
a bit deeper and ask those questions
that other people aren't asking like i
said i'll keep going back to do things
that other people aren't doing so if
they're telling you a lot of things that
you've got a lot of information to take
in from people training you i would say
still
learn everything be a sponge
but then also go back after and ask
further questions just make sure you
really understand everything you're
learning and if there is anything
you're even remotely not 100 sure about
then i would say get clarity on it um
anyone any good trainer will also always
be happy to help people who are willing
to sort of go above and beyond in terms
of learning
so know your market anything specific
about ender spin specific around like
growing your contract book winning
clients getting whiffled projects like
anything specific around that that has
really played out for you that's come
from training do you think
um
yeah i love lots of smaller things um
so people want the smaller things george
these people love so don't you may think
it's not a big deal or it's not that
thing but actually it might be for a lot
of people that's what i asked oh yeah
that's fair enough makes complete sense
i mean i'd say write write things down
so i've got um a whole folder on my work
computer of uh different bd notes and
documents i've made just sort of over
spare time or whatever um so i know for
example like when i've got a manager
call i've got one document i open every
time
where it tells me all my ways of
handling different objections
all my things to probe on and get
further clarity on all my different
intros of ways i might introduce myself
to different managers depending on what
they're looking for or what industry
they're in um or if we've got if we if
it's a cold call or if it's slightly
warmer um yeah so i'd say write
everything down
and then sort of compartmentalize stuff
depending on the activity you're doing
so i i sort of wrote a um candidate
qualification sheet when i first started
um and now that's sort of
in commonplace for the new people at
montage so people get sent that by their
manager and then sort of all the new
people you always see open on their
screens when they're doing candidate
qualifications and that's just because i
was like i want to get the most out of
this initial call because it is the
first point of contact so you want to do
it properly um so i would make notes and
every time i had a call i'd think about
what i can add to it i can adapt how i
can adapt it um one other thing i would
say is um
this is a really good thing you can
implement sort of in the background past
it quite passively um whenever you're
having a call
think about if it goes wrong think about
the point when it goes wrong and really
notice the point where the manager
you're speaking to switches off or the
candidate you're speaking to loses
interest um and then
on your next call jump jump straight
into the next call because it is very
easy to fall off a bit and be like oh no
i had a bad call i'm a bit nervous no i
don't want to pick up the phone so i
would say don't let yourself think like
that jump back on the next call but
consciously thinking
that's the point where
the person lost interest before so i'm
going to do that differently and then if
you keep doing it differently and keep
your sort of naturally just get further
and closer into calls and uh
to the point where you can be talking to
someone 10 minutes and they're just not
switching off to you
thanks for showing that george
yeah build a recruitment brain
yeah i love that super smart so you've
mentioned it a couple of times again i
just have to ask
but like what would your advice be
for someone listening to this who is
like [ __ ] scared of doing cold calls
it sounds like you're doing a bit of
them you're
my advice is it gets easier i guess
every everyone has to do the cold course
to start and like i said it's about
putting in the graft early on um to make
yourself stand out from other recruiters
um so yeah i mean also remember these
people they are just people
realistically you're not going to see
them face to face if you're working a
remote work a remote market and so we i
focus on sort of germany and some areas
of eastern europe and the likelihood is
i'm never going to see these people face
to face unless we actively arrange it
together so i mean just remember you
don't have to meet these people face to
face so it's like if it goes wrong or
you embarrass yourself it's not not that
bad everyone everyone's been through
something similar at least a few at
least a few times um and also i mean
when you're speaking to managers they're
just the same as candidates but with a
couple more years experience uh that's
something i got told by my trainer as
well and it really stayed with me so
it's just sort of like when i'm a lot of
people get nervous speaking to a manager
it's like the ceo or cto of a big
business by the end of the day they're
just like anyone else you're talking to
throughout the day with a couple more
years experience so i mean i wouldn't
worry about it too much
so as we come to the end here then like
i think you've shared some really great
things george but i guess a good sort of
thing that people would like to hear so
like with what you've learned so far the
journey that you've been on i've seen
none or so much in like what would your
advice be for someone who like really
wants to have the best possible start to
their career they want to be
the person that does
continue on and they're not part of the
six or seven people that didn't make it
so like yeah what would your advice be
from knowing what you know now um for
people starting out and to have the best
possible start
um i guess quite quite a few things
probably um remind yourself it's a long
game um results will come but first
you've got to lay the groundwork um
learn as much as you can ask questions
from not just your manager but from
anyone around you who you can see is
doing well
so you can get as many people's
perspectives on routes to success as
possible
um build your knowledge so you have as
many different tools to use
and therefore you can be as successful
as possible
do what other people don't definitely is
a big one i've sort of drilled in um
whether that's working longer hours or
using different strategies to show
managers you're more worthy of their
attention and other recruiters
uh definitely definitely educate
yourself on negotiation and people
skills read chris voss and never split
the difference
and then just sort of learn about how to
be as approachable as possible and how
to get the most out of people in a
non-manipulative way
and then
try not to rely too heavily on caffeine
i guess
i love that
final question george uh look why why do
you think more people should consider a
criminal recruitment right george you
you didn't know about this industry you
didn't know about this career and you
seemed so engaged so excited with yeah
yeah what you can build for yourself so
this is why i'm so passionate about
having more people like you share look
it's been hard but it's been worthwhile
and i'm excited and this is
a really great career choice for people
so like why do you think more people
should consider it as a career choice
um so
i would start with a little mini
disclaimer i don't think it is for
everyone uh i don't think everybody
graduates should consider it because
like i said if you want a job where you
can just clock in work clock out and
you're done then you should probably do
something else i mean again it's fine
but to be the best recruitment
consultant that you possibly can you
need to be driven to go past this
working extra hours handling urgent
client requests in the evenings and just
generally sort of doing things to go
above and beyond the basic requirements
um but i mean if if you are willing to
do that then it the the opportunities to
be successful get financial freedom are
kind of endless and it's it's all down
to
whatever amount of work rate you want to
put in and if you are a hard-working
person or you feel like you could be a
hard-working person but you need
something to really just pull that out
of you then um it's a great starting
point
love it george thank you so much kudos
to you
and uh look uh yeah really excited to
see how your career evolves like
absolutely love your mindset i love your
sort of clearly have a great commitment
to you're trying to maximize your
potential and that's what this is all
about so yeah uh congrats so far
uh i hope you uh achieved the goals that
you have for your first year
and uh george thank you so much for
joining me thanks so much for having me
here